okay I think I am on air good morning
here in Palm Springs California good
afternoon good evening wherever you are
today I want to talk about efficiency
and intensity and the reason the subject
came up is that this year there is heard
of like a a 50-year anniversary year for
me in October my wife and I will
celebrate our 50th wedding anniversary
50 years ago in the spring of 1969 I was
preparing for my British foreign service
exam in mended Chinese and I remember
thinking at the time because I had
managed to cover in ten months what the
other diplomatic language students in
Hong Kong whether they be from Japan the
US Britain wherever they were Canada
they were taking two years and yet I
think you know I did better than they
did I spoke better either stood better
and I felt at that time that one of the
reasons was the intensity of my approach
to learning Chinese like I was going out
at six seven hours a day
I want to do but covers in in that
course I wanted to do it in one year not
in two and I felt that the sort of the
white heat of my intensity in fact
helped me learn it better then those who
were doing it over a longer period of
time so I felt at that time that it's
better to work doubly hard in a limited
period of time to create the intensity
that makes that acquisition period more
effective I had no proof of that but I
felt that to be the case so I was
thinking about that and I was thinking
about how the whole issue of intensity
and efficiency and effectiveness you
know influence is what I now do in
language learning so I thought I would
share some of my thoughts with you and
get some feedback from you and when I
think of my language learning like
before I went to Hong Kong the language
that I had there say the first language
that I could say that I
really achieved fluency in was French
and I did that by leaving the classroom
and totally sort of immersing myself
intensively immersing myself in French
language content movies that remember
that new vent vive the new movies at
first I watched them didn't understand
what they were talking about and
eventually I did I did a lot of reading
and a person in Montreal like I was at
McGill University for two years before I
left but I would go over at the
University of Montreal and sit in which
is the French language University in
Montreal and listen in on lectures not
understand anything but kind of it was
all part of my intensive version in
French and then as a result of all that
I went to France ride them for three
years and and studied in French so
everything was happening in French so
it's a very intense French experience
when I live in France used to hitchhike
into Spain and so I would be 6 hours a
day riding in a truck with a French
truck at least a Spanish truck driver
speaking at first and halting Spanish
and eventually better and better because
I would I went there many times this was
during Franco's time and I can remember
being in a truck with this truck driver
for six hours and then he had to stop
and he of course had a bed in his cab
and I slept in the ditch and climbed
back in the next morning and we
continued on and they were having Spain
in those days was was amazing I remember
once coming into Barcelona
getting on a bus with my rucksack and
that people helped me on with the
rucksack and then they said come on over
to our local bar and of course they
poured out this their wine in this glass
thing that had a lawn spa and you've got
to aim it right out of your mouth or
else you get it all over your shirt so
lots of different intense experiences
with Spanish but if I look at my
language right now and the other thing
that made me think about this intensity
thing is I suddenly noticed that link of
a sudden the loading of the lesson set
has become much faster so if I had a
long 20 minute 25 minute lesson that I
had brought in from
test and then of course the
corresponding text it would take 20
seconds to load and and also I think the
more content you have in a language the
longer these things take to load because
the system has to you know compare your
known words against what's in your
database I don't know what the system
does but it used to take time they've
now sped it up at my longest you know
podcast from al-jazeera
they're up in three four seconds so a
small thing but every little small thing
affects the intensity and the efficiency
of your learning experience and you know
we see this and other things in life for
example I don't know if many of you play
golf but in golf if if your ball sort of
lands just in front of the green so you
have to chip onto the green where the
hole is and so you have either a pull
cart or you're driving a card and if you
leave that in front of the green chip
onto the green and putt out
you then have to walk back to where your
cart is in order to move on to the next
tee box
whereas what you're supposed to do and
what some people don't do you're
supposed to park your cart on that side
of the green which is in the direction
of the next tee box so that you don't
walk back you walk to the side so the
people behind you can hit the ball and
if on 18 holes if you wait 30 seconds on
each hole that's nine minutes that's
nine minutes that the whole course is
backed up because everybody is playing
sort of right on the heels of the next
person as you're going around the golf
course so it's just an example you know
if everybody took 15 seconds less over
every stroke or every pot again it just
speeds it up for everyone and so every
little thing yeah I remember when I
started learning Russian like Russian I
was two years before I started speaking
whereas now with Farseer Persian and
Arabic I'm speaking quite early
I attribute some of that to the many
stories which I think are very efficient
but also I
can remember learning Russian than going
through these Russian texts and link was
so slow that it would take 3-4 seconds
or longer for each word that I looked up
you know to come up in our online
dictionaries and now they're instant so
all of these little things speed up the
efficiency of the learning process I
remember when I was learning Chinese for
example I wouldn't use a standard
dictionary because it's so inefficient
it's a very inefficient to use a [ __ ] in
a Chinese dictionary because you have to
go by stroke count or by radical or by
some other means or if you know how the
word is pronounced and you have a
Chinese dictionary which is organized
alphabetically insert English you might
be able to find it more quickly but it's
quite time-consuming to look up a word
in a Chinese dictionary and then adds
with any dictionary the minute you close
the dictionary eight times out of ten
you've forgotten what the meaning was so
I would never do that I would always I
would scour the bookstores in Hong Kong
to find readers which had word lists
behind every story and the problem with
word lists of course is that very often
the word you're looking for is not a
word list and the word list is full of a
lot of words that you already know so
it's not ideal but those words that I
couldn't find a meaning for I just left
them didn't matter so to that extent
again the fact that with online
dictionaries you can click on a word and
see it right away see examples are but
nowadays you know if you're learning a
language where you have conjugations
which is not the case with Chinese but
then you can see the conjugations
syllable at our fingertips all of this
increases the efficiency of language
learning and every little bit of
efficiency increases the intensity of
the language experience by the way
talking about intensity when I do
flashcards its language exposure to me
and therefore I put all of the
information on the front of the
flashcard and I'll do this sometimes
between pages in a lesson that link and
because I want I sort of concentrated
more intense exposure to
some of the words and phrases that I
didn't get and I still don't feel that I
know in the in the lesson but I don't
want to be scratching my brain I don't I
don't believe it is efficient in terms
of life I was learning to be trying to
remember something I'm also against any
form of question about what you know was
the meaning of this that or the other
the sort of comprehension questions that
people give you where you're forced to
try to remember the story but that's not
the same as getting more intense
exposure to the language that's why for
example in our many stories we you know
we have the to sort of you know point of
view column versions of the same story
and then we have the questions and in
the questions the answer is given to you
so you don't have to scratch your brain
which I consider to be a diversion from
absorbing the language it says you know
Steve went to the store the Steve went
to the grocery store did Steve go to the
library no he didn't order the library
he went to the grocery store so the
answer is given to you
I consider that it creates more
intensity that's for example why I'm not
a big fan of using movies or video as a
learning tool I think movies or video
are great as a stimulus it's fun it's
exciting
I can remember my excitement when I
watched my first movies in Russia and
these were Soviet era movies one was the
first one I ever watched which is one of
my favorite movies of all times was not
that it's based on a play called been
spreadin it's a-- and it was just
Okinawa's fabulous exotic Russia on the
Volga in the nineteenth century I mean I
was just like wow I gotta get out this
so it's tremendously stimulating however
in any movie it's less word intense than
pure audio or pure reading I remember my
disappointment after listening to you
know some Guan Yi which is the Romance
of the Three
kingdoms told by a Chinese storyteller
and the Chinese storytelling art that
it's like phenomenal you can almost
smell the dust listening to the words
and it's all coming from words and then
I watched a movie of Sango yen is just a
bunch of people flying around sword
fighting and you know horses challenge
Chara and it's just not as intense a
language experience so I believe that
intensity word intensity Audio word
intensity listening reading making sure
that you maximize the time that you
spend with the language and every little
trick that makes the language learning
experience more intense that pays a lot
of dividends and I remember thinking and
I think I mentioned this in my book the
way of the linguist I think was called
which I wrote yeah over 10 years ago
that that the the benefits of intensity
are sort of geometrical in other words
if you have learned it twice as fast you
don't just learn it twice as well maybe
you learn it three times as well so all
of that add and and that's why for the
longest time I was against the idea of
learning more than one language at one
time but here I am learning Arabic and
farsi or perched so what has changed
well I just think that the language
learning environment has become so much
more efficient and so you know I get on
LinkedIn I can see 10 languages I could
jump into any one of them right now they
go and I could do many stories or novels
or whatever I want it's just become so
much more convenient plus maybe also I'm
sacrificing some intensity no question
because I'm curious to sort of dabble in
both languages so it's it's also a
matter of what your what your motives
are if I had a deadline if I was being
paid by my government as was the case
with Chinese fifty years ago
to learn Arabic then I would obviously
spend all my time on Arabic and I would
go at it not an hour or two a day but
six or seven hours a day and I'm
convinced that I would learn that Arabic
in six or seven months much as I did
with with Chinese and I would learn it
faster because the whole old language
learning environment Petrey mp3
technology the resources on the internet
all of that has become so much more
efficient that I have no doubt that if I
were to commit myself to full-time study
of Arabic it would be a matter for a
year before I have to be you know
comfortably reading newspapers
conversing and so forth so so that's
kind of the main theme today and I mean
before going on I am going to have a
quick look at any questions that might
have been presented to me or comments so
let me just go here at the beginning
don't know them I'm all right
not a very good morning hi Steve dueling
the language teachers in Tennessee Emily
hi Steve Onion SEO Eric I have a few
questions for Marcus okay so bla bla
Mendoza I already started so you said a
is more effective to study four hours a
day for 25 days or one hour a day for a
hundred days no question four hours a
day for 25 days I believe and I have no
scientific you know proof of that nah it
may very well be that there is a sort of
gestation period I've often felt this
that even after I learn something it
takes a while for the brain to sort of
absorb it so is 25 days just simply too
short a period of time it's possible I
have noticed that if I study something
and leave it and I come back to it later
it's actually I've gotten a better grasp
on it so it may very well be that four
hours a day for 25 days is not enough
that there may be a critical period like
three months that you need and it will
also depend on
languages you know and let the languages
you're learning and stuff like that but
as a general rule that sort of
specifically addressing this for an hour
today for 25 days versus one hour a day
for a hundred days and even assuming
like how do you really control for that
like when I say I study an hour a day
some days I studied two hours some days
I study forty minutes half an hour not
at all
- difficult to say specifically but as a
general rule at least in my experience
six months of intensive study is better
than two years of not intensive study
but untested focuses on occasional favor
let's say recommend for recommend a folk
art I mean it's the same what do you
recommend focus on teacher achieve of be
one big one is actually not a very high
level and if you do a lot of listening
and reading I actually think that our
many stories take you to be one and
that's in fact if I say here's a
language X Turkish you have to get to be
one I would do the many stars
I would totally focus on the many
stories I would listen to the many times
and one thing by the way when I say
listen to the many stories 3040 times
I'm not saying that you take the first
mini story listen to it 30 times I
listen to the last one once or twice
it's all foggy fuzzy I listen to Les
Deux foggy fuzzy less than three then I
go back to lesson one two three four
doctor one two three four five and so I
keep on progressing because we do have
to have you know I begin you know I want
to get to a new story because I'm tired
of this one story the brain cannot you
cannot listen to the same story I can't
over and over and over again you have to
go forward and come back go forward and
come back that keeps it a little fresher
and then you're happy to rediscover a
story that you listen to before didn't
understand hardly anything and now you
understand more so yeah I would focus on
the many stories
hello for polish your chest hey Steve
hello Frankie boy one day maybe
Hungarian blah blah blah excuse me I
have a question if you are going to read
two articles one is a lot of new words
and
there's only a few new words which one
will help you most for learning
languages you know theoretically the
more new words the more new words can
say you can acquire but if the if the
text is full sort of has too many new
words then it's too tough you're not
enjoying it there's no sort of fluency
there's no sense of flow you know that
there's a famous Hungarian I think he
was a thinker who talked about the sense
of flow the sense of flow and his that
his name was cheese Chesley highly
difficult to pronounce he to him flow
was when you had a task that was
difficult yet you felt you could
overcome the obstacles you could achieve
success so if you're in a situation
where it's too easy
there's no sense of flow but if you have
a sense that you're struggling with a
task that is difficult but you're
confident that you can achieve your goal
that is flow that's the ideal situation
to be it so if you have I think for me
personally if I have texts that are 10%
new words that's good 20% new words is
getting tough 5% new words is too few so
you have to find that sort of sweet spot
where it's a challenge but you don't
find it too difficult so I would say you
know you the question is a little bit
vague here
absenting which is something we measure
at link I think 10% 15% new words
somewhere between 5 and 15 this is what
I would go for Steve I'm learning French
do you talk about the value in listening
while I listen only and not read along I
can only understand the artwork and what
is that is this Stila value well you
know we all struggle with this we can
obviously we can read better than we can
understand when we listen because when
we read look words up we have the time
we didn't quite get it the first time we
read the sentence again it makes sense
plus we know the words when we see them
we may not recognize the words when we
hear them so here it's simply a matter
of giving the chance a giving you the
brain
a chance to get used to it the brain
learns I say this all the time I quote
Manfred Spitzer the brain can all be
cannot do otherwise then learn the brain
is a learning machine but the brain
learns slowly so you have to feed the
brain in all the time lots of exposure
and in the case of this comprehension
thing go back and read again review the
words and phrases listen again go back
again and grab annalee you'll understand
more and more and also don't forget what
I said about don't don't overdo the
repetition like if I'm doing a mini
story I'm not going to listen to one
mini story ten times right there my
brain will say no thanks
the brain does require some novelty some
refreshment so I go one two three four
five six back to one and so forth and so
on up to ten back to one so that in time
you understand more the brain will get
used to hearing the sounds ok now hi
Steve what do you think about complete
immersion the target language for
example Gordon country study doing
reading many stories blah blah blah ok
obviously you know if you're in the
country where the language is spoken you
have lots of potential exposure to the
language so that's kind of ideal but a
couple of things on that I learned
Mandarin Chinese in Hong Kong where no
one spoke Mandarin just about Noah so it
you don't have to go to the country to
learn the language in Japan I lived
surrounded by the language which is an
advantage I could go to a store buy
something say a few things in Japanese
and feel good about myself because I was
able to do something in Japanese so it
is an advantage but I was not stent I
didn't go to Japan to learn Chinese my
government sent me to Japan to work at
the Canadian embassy I was there anyway
I'm gonna take advantage of it if your
goal is to go to the language to work if
you go to the country to work on your
language prepare yourself first in other
words get yourself to a level where you
can actually do something in the
language because if you arrive with
nothing then you're gonna spend the
first few months doing what you could
have done at home
intensive listening and reading
and so then then when you get to the
country all of a sudden you looked
around you read to understand the signs
you can read the newspaper you can order
something go to a store in other words
you hit the ground running and that's my
sort of best practices if it is your
goal and it's really good to have as
well I want to go to the country so
that's the motivation and then work very
hard at home to get yourself to a b1
level let's say and then go to the
country and then you will do very well
okay my plan is just start speaking
Japanese at two years I should have a
six to eight Cosmo cabaret that speaking
area results in about that I don't think
speaking early results in a bad accent
or anything else because you most of the
sort of influence on your accent is
going to be what you listen to and you
won't listen to massive amounts of
native speaker hopefully say Japanese
and that's what's gonna if you're open
to it and flexible and willing to take a
chance with trying to pronounce things
and you start to hear the language
better all of that is going to matter
the most
yeah you're gonna pronounce very poorly
at the beginning it doesn't matter when
you start you're gonna pronounce poorly
if you have done a lot of listening
you'll probably pronounce better at the
beginning but if you have a few inter
interactions in the language at an early
stage I don't think that has any
negative effect on you as long as you
remain open as like if you continue to
notice what's happening in the language
my physicians speaking earlier late
depends on your opportunity depends on
your information I don't think it has a
particularly positive or negative effect
on your learning the bulk of your
learning is input activity okay I had
trouble import a news article with the
extension today okay
this is Swedish Finn a francophone
Franco please report any of this on the
forum maybe other people oh here again
another one a link extension has start
working for me I tried different browser
but no life so we have two people
recording this I will report this and of
course it's always good to report this
on the forum because there are things
that have
and if other people are having sometimes
we never know if it's an individual
problem relating to some setup of theirs
or if it's more common problem so this
looks like it might be a more common
problem but again if you don't mind
reporting it on the form in any case I
will report into the office after this
session it's hard to read an article has
a lot of new words yeah that's true you
don't believe that being forced to
recall words occasionally helps force
the neural pathway in the brain for when
you begin output no I don't I find that
sort of when I this is the mini stories
and I hear certain words and phrases
over and over again that forges new
neural pathways path pathways I'm not
convinced of trying to recollect a word
is forging a new pathway because I feel
languages is more of a habit we're
developing new habits we're developing
new habits not acquiring new knowledge
we're we're forging new sort of language
habits but I'm sure there's research out
there that proves me wrong but that's my
impression okay Steve is an T SRS I have
no idea why yeah I am auntie auntie srf
yes I don't use SRS very much
lots of people do lots people love it
that's fine
people should do what they like to do I
feel that I have a limited amount of
time to spend with the language I prefer
to spend it listening and reading
overwhelmingly listening now
if there were some SRS listening that I
could do where on some basis they words
that I should be learning it all showed
up and an audio file that I could take
with me I would listen to that but to
actually sit down and go through
flashcards when I have thousands of
unknown words would simply be too
time-consuming it's not where I want to
spend my time if anyone has an idea on
how to create audio files natural voice
of the words that you're that are high
on your SRS spaced repetition system
list that's something I might be
interested in words that phrases but
it's a tell you up to what people like
to do
as far as literature as you know and
remember what you think you do know it's
that's not true you can learn something
and then it's forgotten again and and if
it shows up six months later and you you
you know see it and your SRS that can
review it that maybe that helps to
trigger the recollect but the same thing
would happen if you were reading context
and came across it I'm not convinced
that you know there's so many emotional
and other things that affect why you
remember certain words maybe you're
asked for a ward you get it wrong for
whatever reason maybe you knew that word
you didn't you know you were under some
stress and stuff I just don't buy it but
people who enjoy whatever you enjoy
doing go for it
also in Vancouver John was wondering if
I can ever hope to see you at one of the
local I'd love to you know send me a
note Steve at link comm I'm in Palm
Springs right now but I'll be back in
mid-april sent me a note I'd be glad to
come out okay I need an English native
speaker you can sign up with a tutor
somewhere and everything is more
important than English know that link
needs Hindi if people will come up with
Hindi content we'll put them up there
somebody gave us the 60 mini stories in
Gujarati and we have Gujarati if someone
gives us Hindi we'll put it up now to
learn Chinese intonation cheers from a
LaRussa you know intonation when III
think it's a lot of listening it's
focusing on phrasing because it's very
difficult to remember the individual
tone of each individual word but if you
get used to saying certain phrases and
if you heard these phrases as in the
mini stores for example and you hear
them and hear them and hear them then
they start to become natural and so you
come up with natural phrasing using the
tones and I've said before that I did a
lot of listening to sunshine sunshine
are Chinese
sort of comedians to comedians talking
to each other and of course their whole
intonation is very much exaggerated and
so your exposure is exaggerated in today
and I found that helpful to give me a
bit of a the rhythm of the upper tones
okay what has the language you know best
other than English French I don't use
mnemonic linked words no I've never been
willing to invest in that some people
use that as a strategy I don't you know
I'm basically listening and reading and
eventually speaking learning Spanish I
can say that I understand quite well
Scott Walker says but I feel like I
can't get back with normal TV shows sure
I lived in Japan for nine years it took
me a long time to understand Japanese TV
shows even though I was doing business
in Japanese so it's difficult to
understand TV shows you're not in that
you know context so you're kind of a
bystander and it's it's more difficult
and the only way you get there is to do
more and more listening okay okay
Steve sensei in dakara konnichiwa hello
Foreman yeah I'm Japanese okay me Holly
she sent me Holly yeah he is great okay
uh uh iced tea this is my first text and
Englishness ever I would like to know
how many hours a student should have to
be to be considered an advance listener
I don't know the answered that question
but you know if you is some an hour a
day that's 365 hours a year I think a
thousand like I remember when I lived in
Japan they had a challenge a thousand
hours of listening I think that's a good
goal a thousand hours of listening a
couple with reading of course you don't
want to just listen to things that you
don't understand Steve when are you
gonna learn Dutch yeah I mean I'd like
to right now I'm sort of motivated to
learn you know Persian Arabic Turkish
you know the whole Central Asian Middle
East area but I've had a look at Dutch
at Lane
and I feel it wouldn't be very difficult
I mean the grammar I don't know what but
hidden shoals that are there but
certainly in terms of vocabulary doesn't
look that difficult
I might it's not high on my list right
now I used to listen focus more but he
talked about you're a team in the
language many times so I started this
new years and it really makes me like
you really you know well you know
language is a Jo is a great guy like
he's very enthusiastic
I think enthusiasm is extremely
important because language learning is a
fun thing to do it should be fun and you
need a high degree of motivation and
enthusiasm to stay with it because at
times it looks like we're not making
much progress and we have to stay with
it because eventually we do make
progress and we sort of sometimes we
have excessive expectations of what we
can achieve in the short run and we
don't realize just how much we achieve
in the long run
hi Steve how do I go from good to great
and reading Japanese but when I'm
reading a now I have to look up a lot of
words in the dictionary oh this is from
miss iris
silver silver ah money yeah novels are
hard
there is no question novels is the most
if are the most difficult things
nonfiction newspapers history
translations all of these things are
easier when we get into novels this is
creative literature in the language
we're gonna be dealing with more
difficult vocabulary rare low-frequency
vocabulary I mean what I do is I import
these things into link I get the e-text
version I bring it into link and then
that just becomes part of my learning if
I'm gonna read your novel and you're
reading language that I'm fairly good at
like German I would bring it into Lake
Russia in the same way just learn those
words because there's gonna be a lot of
unknown words in literature okay
will you guys ever make link shirts we
should thank you I will get on the
office okay hey man
how are you okay when you go to a
foreign country how do you create our
future yourself to speak other than the
taxi rides a homemade beer yeah so
here's some examples I spent a year
learning Czech mostly listening and
reading on my own and then I had some
online tutors so I arranged to spend
seven hours a day speaking Czech six
hours so I had to our online tutor so
that's an hour each and I think I knew
some people that I spoke to
and then I happen to be at lunch and I
struck up a conversation with some
people sitting beside me it's difficult
when I was in Latin America Argentina
Brazil and Peru I would say most of my
conversations were with taxi drivers
which is a good deal down there because
the taxi drivers aren't that expensive
so it's it's a good deal similarly when
I was in Morocco
most of my conversations in Standard
Arabic were with taxi drivers not all
taxi driver spoke Standard Arabic it is
difficult yeah you can go into a store
you have a brief interaction but it's
very limited it is he's kind of good
though because even if you're fairly
good in the language if you go in a
given situation you know you go into a
store you go in you know your whatever
at the train station you don't really
know what they're gonna throw at you
like you have the words but you're not
used to doing that so the first time you
do it it's a bit clumsy because they
don't you know I had the same experience
in Ukraine they don't consider
themselves language teachers you're just
another person buying a ticket so
they're you know you and you kind of
have to think through what did she
actually say then the second time you go
there now you're ready for it right so
it is kind of fun to do those things to
have these short interactions in the
language but extensive exchanges
conversations unless you know people is
kind of difficult yeah that's all I can
say okay
you just learning a fictional language
what are you going oh they're fictional
language like Klingon not in the
slightest
I like to learn languages that are
spoken by people in a country where I
can get into the history culture of a
language possibly run into people who
speak those languages sitting beside me
like when I was flying from iguazu
brazil to to rio and the gentleman
sitting beside me was a Paraguayan of
ukrainian origin and we spoke a little
spanish today we spoke Ukrainian that's
fun I don't expect the sit beside
someone who speaks Klingon ok I can
realize when I try to speak my verb
lenses get confused of course verb
tenses are tough it's likely the case
endings in Slavic languages it's
something we're not used to if we're
English speakers
it takes a long time to get used to it's
easy to understand the principle yeah I
mean even in English
how many non-native speakers still can't
get the fact that the third person
singular of the present takes takes
present tense to make some s you know
whatever he he go he go or the you get
that all the time it's difficult to
forge new habits what I do with
conjugation that is for example in
Spanish there's a number of conjugations
that give me trouble and you don't want
to be thinking about them so say if I'm
at lang I save a word I use context
reversal or conjugated one of those
conjugating dictionaries I then go
quickly review the conjugation for that
verb and leave it I can't remember it
but it's just it just reminds me reminds
me you just keep on doing that keep on
doing that I keep on hearing it keep on
reminding yourself of where that fits in
and slowly the brain develops you have
it and it's like with cases in Slavic
languages with tones in Chinese you
orbit with gender you know you're gonna
gradually improve your your accuracy
you're gonna go from 50 to 60 to 70 to
80 and you'll never be perfect and you'd
then but you just gotta keep on doing
Jim resin cement American spirit and
steering disco yeah what's there between
an American English all right first of
all within North American English
because I throw Canadian in there and
sort of British English there are
regional variations so overwhelmingly
the difference is pronunciation but
there are some words that are used that
and say a North American would
understand unless it's slang would
understand in say British English but
wouldn't necessarily use and vice versa
so there's some minor differences of
vocabulary the biggest difference is in
pronunciation yeah that's what I would
say in my it's Princeton thank you I'm
glad in my opinion it translates the
easiest in the world which have been the
most useful language you've learned so
far they give you the most satisfaction
Wow
satisfaction they all give me
satisfaction I mean this evening we have
a birthday party for my wife and we've
invited in people here in the
neighborhood including a couple from who
are originally from Iraq
living in the States for thirty plus
years I am hoping to speak to them in
Persian that gives me immense
satisfaction you know it gives me
satisfaction to be able to understand I
see Koreans Chinese Russians French
Brazilians I can understand them that
nothing seems that foreign to me and
hopefully soon that'll be the case with
Arabic and Persian as well obviously in
terms of from a business perspective the
most useful language has been Japanese
because I lived there for nine years I
did business in Japanese I built up my
lumber business based on doing business
in Japan so I would say Japanese has
been the most useful professionally but
in terms of a sexual satisfaction they
all give me satisfaction okay I love you
do you wait a second
do you putting a point for you I don't
understand I love your videos are
learning in foreign I've become good
enough to watch movies without subs and
I have a decent accent how can I take
you to the next level to take it but if
you love your learning if you just keep
on doing it reading read novels watch
movie
talk to people all of that is continuing
to improve as long as you're still
curious about the language now we have
immigrants who will say come to Canada
they're not curious about the language
that are interested in learning and they
don't improve but if you're motivated to
improve and you're eager to learn new
words and you're exposing yourself to
the language and you're speaking when
you can without worrying about it you
will improve it we'll take it to the
next level in you of course don't be
anxious okay what is your opinion on the
aj ATT method I can't comment because I
don't know enough about it and I you
know I don't want to comment based on
the superficial understanding how much
should I understand what I'm reading or
listening to in order for it to count as
comprehensible input do I need a vivid
image in my mind of what is being
described no I feel that as I'm
listening to stuff I mean take person I
mean I started from scratch with the
ministers it was just noise didn't
understand a thing and we don't have
good dictionaries for perch like there
are no good online dictionaries for
perch and we don't have text-to-speech
which I found very useful for Arabic so
there were a lot of things going against
me and I would listen and not understand
more than 20 30 percent but it's all
good it's all gradual and then you
reread and then you listen and you
slowly improve so comprehensible input
to me
means that maybe you know you have at
least a possibility of getting to where
you understand so you have to have a
transcript and it shouldn't be too
difficult for you but initially it's
gonna be very difficult because you know
nothing
and so you gradually gradually get to
where you understand more and more I
tend to move on to new material even
though I only understand 70% of what I
was this need and this is this whole
thing between repetition and novelty so
you can't keep on listening to the same
stuff over and over again the brain
starts to get less and less interested
so it's kind of have to vary it but I
think I don't see any hard and fast rule
that it has to have X percent you know
comprehensible content for the thing to
be considered a comprehensible input
okay I am
all right how much okay
I'm afraid you make mistakes we cannot
use while I think you should to use it
the more can you ask you make mistake
you cannot use I don't understand the
question I an intermediate but I can't I
can just read your book that by the way
is incredible can you say that I now
know more than 5000 words if you read my
book you probably know more than 5000
words Bitcoin is simple says you skipped
my question well I can't go back it's a
long list here you ask the question
again if I come across it I won't answer
it how to improve listening effectively
I've been learning for a long time right
listening you talk like so much in
language I just gotta keep doing it but
combine the listing with reading I don't
memorize okay okay good sir you
shouldn't you yes any question here
about SRS I did use a sort of a modified
SRS version to learn the first thousand
characters in Chinese okay I have the
same level how to change it I'm fed up
with it I live in art I mean one of the
things is get a novel get a novel for
which you can find the audio book I mean
if I if you're a member of link import
the novel by it take the digital version
import it into link I have fun Oh once
you have actually conquered a novel read
it listen to it that really elevates
your your level of confidence in the
language it really gets you into the
language once you've done one you can do
another so that's one thing I would
recommend okay links are high so English
better always for yo-yo contests Aleman
yep okay yes
a little okay good idea I would love
some linked socks
you mean combine and I don't should I do
when I read a novel right now I am
reading on right well my approach to
learning a novel is that I bring it into
link so I can save all the words Keith
no my Arabic reading is not good K
Fattah al LaMotte
Steve safe I don't know I I I'm working
on having it's a work in progress
yeah language learning is the social
activity I agree and interacting with
books and content listening and reading
is also a social activity did you ever
think you've reached 150 house no I had
no idea what I'm gonna do you know
I am gonna get back to these Arabic
texts but ye bothe too tough for me you
a german do it called sandwich man yeah
okay according to the US forest it takes
more hours for the returned Japanese any
other language included you what I think
this is I have no idea
I don't think Japanese is that difficult
but then I had the Chinese characters
ahead time I didn't find you happenes
particularly difficult to Mughal child
yawn okay
yeah when they are Chun you know how do
you get good at Chinese no different you
learn the characters and you do a lot of
listening ready I will be Chris here
yeah at this point you know I'm thinking
of going to Fukuoka to the polyglot
conference and of course to the long
fest in Montreal and so I just can't be
going to everyone so I'm gonna skip by
Bratislava
exciting time to be alive isn't it yes
you know when I hear so much negativity
about the world today
there are real problems there are real
problems in in the you know as an
example I play golf here with the
gentleman who had been who had worked
for 44 years in a sawmill in British
Columbia and he's got he's challah he
holidays here in Palm Springs he was a
work for 44 years and he has a pension
and he's able to holiday in Palm Springs
those kinds of opportunities are fewer
today somebody with limited education
who would have a good without paying job
and end up with a good pension and as a
house and so forth so those are problems
we have to address those problems there
are problems of inequity there are
problems that a very small number of
people seem to making you know getting
all of the wealth and society and so
these are issues that have to be
addressed there are issues with climate
but we have a degree of connectivity
with the world like I'm talking to
people all over the world right now we
have means to solve these problems if we
apply ourselves to these real problems
it's an exciting time to be alive
absolutely I agree with that I like to
get optimistic comments from people do
you have some language they would like
to neglect for example you don't like it
or afraid to learn it because you think
it is too hard
I hope okay I mean I I have struggled
I've struggled with Korea I'm struggling
now with Arabic and Persian but it never
discourages me it's just that some
languages are more difficult than others
the writing system is always a problem
now I invested a lot of time and effort
into Chinese characters
I can read Chinese characters more
easily than I can read Hangul or even
katakana and it's just a function of how
much reading I have done in encounter so
but it doesn't discourage me and I want
to get back to my Korean it bothers me
every time I meet Korean people and not
able to speak as well as I would like I
gotta get back there and improve it and
yet now I'm working on bird in Arabic
there's only so many hours I can devote
the language hurting but none that I
would want to neglect why are English
speaking Canadians terrible at French
for Fred speaking Romanian speaking it's
relatively
rather better well there are things
several reasons first of all North
America is 360 million people and out of
which barely six or seven million speak
French so that English is dominant in
North America so the motivation for a
french-canadian to learn English is far
greater than the motivation for an
English Canadian to learn French and I
and the next thing is of course it as in
Europe the media television movies is
dominated by English so that the
exposure to English is far greater
that's why in countries like Sweden for
example young children speaking this
very well because they watch English TV
it's not because the Swedish school
system is better at teaching English
than say you know the French school
system so those are and I also I mean I
don't imagine that the instruction in
English in French schools in Canada is
better than the instruction in French
and English schools so it's purely the
environment motivation being surrounded
by the language on the other hand my
grandchildren speak French because they
went to French immersion so there are
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
English Canadian kids who go to French
immersion so their French is okay those
that go to the standards in Spain in
school a smaller number actually end up
speaking a language that despite the
fact that the government Canadian
government spends I don't know six seven
hundred million dollars a year to motor
promote bilingualism outside go back and
actually bilingualism outside Quebec is
declining I suggest instead of spending
hundreds of millions of dollars that
should put everyone on link ok ok is it
ok to study a third light as you say I
think one or is it better views on your
native language if the second language
is strong then I think it's probably a
good idea it's more a function of what
language learning material you can find
resources and if they're available in a
thirty second language but I all means
go for it do you have any specific
recommendations for beginners listening
material Japanese again I am a fan of
and I not studying Japanese right now so
I cannot recommend anything other than
link maybe other people can well in
reading Chinese I feel I relied too much
on characters I'm Japanese should I
still read okay it's good I mean for the
longest time I read Japanese and every
time I came across a Chinese character I
would pronounce it Chinese in my mind
because that's the pronunciation I was
comfortable with and it took me a long
time to realize that that that character
was in fact this Japanese word that I
heard so often but I didn't necessarily
connect the two I think that's you know
obviously it's it's it's normal but if
you do a lot of listening and reading
and you see the text and you it you have
a big advantage that you know the
meaning and if you're listening to it
and you're reading it gradually you'll
start to identify the most characters
with the Chinese pronunciation I would
also use pinyin if you're on a link you
can get the pinyin to show up and so
that you gradually start to drag that
pinyin pronunciation pronunciation into
your brain it's a matter of time when
you just do listen to multiple small
recordings and repeat how long
everything no I tend to listen to the
lesson so I will know I do a lot of
listening on our playlist of me sorry to
just continue going through it sometimes
if I want to hear the lesson more than
once I'll listen to it in the lesson in
which case it'll repeat but most often I
listen on the playlist so I just listen
I just listened once and it goes to the
next and the unit is the lesson so it
could be one minute long it could be
three minutes five minutes okay I don't
understand this one I'm good I can't
speak Hindi but maybe one day am I gonna
be in Russia you know what I'd love to I
know I am gonna be in Ukraine
mostly eastern Ukraine and Kiev for
their Russian speakers I'd love to go
back to Russia all I saw was st.
Petersburg and Moscow and I would want
to get into you know you know Yaroslav
or
any of these places I am fascinated by
Russian culture absolutely no question
and I will be back into Hindi yeah okay
definitely I have to get started let's
bother when you meet people whose native
language is the one you don't know other
men East Southeast Asia no I mean yeah I
wouldn't have to speak the language of
people I come across but I have to be
realistic I cannot learn ten languages
at once so it doesn't bother me if I
find you know if I come across punjabi
speakers which it would be the most
common South Asian people in Vancouver
yeah if I get in the cab with a Punjabi
driver and I you know and we checked you
know the numbers in pyjama very similar
to numbers and Persia and stuff like
that
and I'd love to put her in the language
but I have to be realistic what do you
think about Qatar loving her method of
reading as soon as possible in a foreign
language without a dictionary yeah so
cattle mom live in you know 100 years
ago or whenever her basic thing is
reading okay when cat Kalam lived we
didn't have mp3 player pairs we didn't
have the mountain of content available
on the internet we didn't have online
dictionaries so I'd be interested in
knowing what her advice would be today I
am NOT a fan of reading without a
dictionary I'm also not a fan of
monolingual dictionaries I believe
they're inefficient I thought this
discussion today was supposed to be
about it you know intensity like I want
right away now though that word what is
kind of roughly the meaning it may be
not exactly what fits this context but
it gets me started in in learning the
word and if I am you know have no idea
what the word is or I have to use a
monolingual dictionary which explains
the word in the language then it's full
of more words that I don't know not for
me okay so yeah who is alarm she is a
very famous Hungarian polyglot and has
written a book and who has a wonderful
formula for language learning let if I'm
remembering now by my memory language
learning is motivation and time divided
by
inhibition frustration other resistance
I really I mean the Mach 35 I love it I
found a lot of new words I looked them
up on the next night or should I guess
the meaning well I tend if I'm good
enough to read the book to enjoy it then
I don't bother looking at words I mean
it's not like those words are gonna run
away eventually they'll show up again
and again another context that you
lament you get a sense of what the word
means
I find again looking words up in the
dictionary is a low effectiveness low
intensity activity is it possible to
talk to native speakers on link yes it
is just look up the tutors or you can
contact someone in our community and set
up your own exchange if you want can we
report anything onto the link jumping
back now that I speak you can import
anything you want for your own use okay
in fact we even have our total you know
book import function however if you want
to share anything in our library you can
only share material for which you have
the copyright now there is either you
created it or it's free of copyright or
you've contacted the owner of the
copyright but for your own use you can
import whatever you want
have you been to Germany absolutely wait
I do think I'd order here I reached good
level of fluency in English a link but
after that I felt that I need more
emotion go the next level like native
conservative what do you recommend well
you know at some point we want to talk
we want to talk a lot like the link is
more than get you to a potential level
on the language so now you have to
engage with people and so the ideal
thing if you have the opportunity to go
to someplace where there's a lot of
English spoken or engage the people
online that's kind of what you have to
do I'm from South to Jeremy I have had
in the 90s I did a lot of business in
Germany I used to travel he's had a chef
come on norge stylist I was again I was
up and down on the Autobahn with my
agent we were speaking German for hours
and I find Germans are very friendly the
little towns are beautiful even in the
big cities of her very modern nice
restaurants and they all have an old
quarter Germany is great and I've been
there many times are you planning on
learning Turkish yes I have read a lot
of books in Cantonese and I'm going to
start learning Mandarin soon how do I
used to reading in manner when all the
Cantonese
slightly into my head um you know I had
the reverse I had to go for Mandarin the
Cantonese just get a lot of text and let
the new pronunciation slide into your
brain that's I think again link would be
very good for that because you you can
be streaming the audio and you can even
have the pinyin because you have the
option of having an opinion show up
above the characters and you understand
the character if you have big advantage
and then you just have to totally and
then you go away and listen to it you go
back and read and eventually and slowly
you will set up another channel another
control center in your brain to handle
Mandarin that was my experience with
Cantonese one of the most useful
languages business-wise that depends
entirely on your business where you are
I mean they're all important somewhere I
can't I can't answer that English I
think as a general statement would be
the most useful I have written an
article reason saying that learning new
language is useless since image is
already done I didn't translate you have
translation have sight development what
is your take on that I love learning
languages I love learning about the
country reading their history hearing
audio books about their history in their
language no language rap is gonna take
that away so if anything I tend to
believe that that English of course is
an extremely useful international
language of exchange if a Japanese
person meets a Brazilian person they can
immediately communicate because they
have English it's not Esperanto it's not
you know Klingon it's English so that's
very useful but that's not what language
learning is about language learning is
about developing and an inroad into a
different culture and then when you
encounter someone of that culture you
can speak to them in their language or
they can speak to you in your language
they're you know driving the benefit
that's what language learning is all
about and language learning is easier
now than it was fifty years ago when I
started okay so I think people are gonna
learn languages faster and they're gonna
use things like automatic translation
and text-to-speech an automatic
dictation and all of these things are
going to be tools enabling people to
learn languages faster and faster as I
am finding that I learn languages faster
today than I ever did I am learning the
last three languages Greek Persian and
Arabic I'm moving along faster than I
did ten years ago not to mention fifty
years ago with Chinese Steve how do you
handle content that you have transcripts
for but not a translation yeah I mean at
least most of our content has transcript
not necessarily a translation I I don't
really use the translations very much I
have an online dictionary I can access
several if it's a language that we're
you know conjugation is an issue I can
even access a conjugation dictionary if
I'm learning you know Korean I can go
find a Chinese character that no longer
shows up in Korean but in fact is there
and then helps me learn and I prefer to
to you know attack our text both in
terms of listening and then eventually
in in in reading and learning so
remaining these texts for words and
phrases and information that's gonna
help these words and phrases stick with
me I'm not so interested in the
translation because the translation kind
of takes me away from that language
context that I want to beat so it to me
it doesn't matter okay do you sometimes
did everything in a foreign language or
talk to yourself and next time
occasionally if I'm spending the whole
day in Japanese or French possibly
Chinese maybe Spanish I might be talking
to myself in that language but it
doesn't happen that often you you should
how are you - yeah I'm studying English
many years I feel like kind of reached
frenzy okay I mean you just got to keep
going and be grateful for what you have
achieved a lot of people they beat
themselves up and criticize themselves
for not being better than what they are
but they forget that sometimes earlier
they couldn't do a thing in that
language so you gue we constantly learn
probably learn slowly from Japan total
good great what is your goal by end of
the 90 days okay I mean my goal is to
know more than when I started
and feel more comfortable and more
confident that I can get better
and that's it I don't necessarily I'm
not going to take a test and I will hope
at some point do maybe a conversation in
both Arabic and Persian and people can
make their own assessment of you know
where was that advice for listening
comprehension in Italian yeah first of
all link and then and there's lots of
good podcast Rai has this I do it a
little della Sera
is a wonderful series get yourself a lot
of interesting content stuff you're
interested in audiobooks blue mallet or
a which is a website they have audio
ebooks they have the audio and the
e-book get those and you can listen to
the literature and you can import the
ebook interlinked so yeah that's what I
recommend
do you know very recommend what do you
think of her cancer yeah I mean her
thing if I remember correctly was that
we should be something to do with with
trying to translate word by word in
order to get a better sense of the
language I have no particular opinion I
find that a lot of these systems it's
whatever you like to do if you get into
that then go for it I don't because I
have a different approach so vaguely
it's the same input based activities and
she has a specific attack there and and
for people to find out efficient and
enjoyable by all means uh any tips on
how to find a language partner on the
internet yeah I mean just google
language partner whatever language
Portuguese in English or whatever it
might be
huh okay fast way to learn Chinese
there's no fast way to learn any
particular languages I mean I say it
over and over again there are no
shortcuts listening and reading and
speak when you're ready okay is it still
too low hydrogen I mean is it still too
late check on the website insofar as the
link 90 days number the wrong time to
commit yourself to intensive involvement
with the language intensity means
success
thanks Jeff a yeah well there's only so
many things you can do
I'm currently learning Chinese what do
you recommend to start writing text by
oneself and remembering characters ha
well you just have I would say today
Google because there are systems for
learning characters that didn't exist
when I was learning them what do I think
is the ugliest language there is no ugly
language how to learn English for
diplomacy English for any special
purpose is simply a matter of finding
that kind of content and doing a lot of
listening really ok there is a Google
Chrome extension supper-table that lets
you download netflix Korean place there
you go sir okay all right very good
how to make kids learn because they
don't really understand yeah
don't you podcast and fail in hobbies
niche there's no special I have no
recommendation for and but have a look
we have some podcasts at link are you
can just turn iTunes into Germany and
then see what podcasts are popular in
Germany how do you make kids learn good
question I don't know but at that I have
to get going because I have a lot of
work to do
here's mine now we're gonna finish off
with it we liberate the levers are it
easy and yet I'm returning in schools in
serious decline it's in serious decline
in the english-speaking world but I'm
not sure that's true everywhere how many
times do you repeat listening to and
reading the same text as I said earlier
I don't repeat it immediately I go
forward and come back for her to come
back but if I look at my playlist I have
listened to some items 3040 times okay I
better get up and I gotta go buy a bunch
of stuff for our birthday party this
evening so thank you for listening bye
for now